so over the past year the Bitcoin
network has reached his maximum capacity
all the blocks are becoming full and as
a result there's been a lot of debate
Howie about how we can scale Bitcoin in
the future so we're talking talk a
little bit about some of those proposals
and what they could mean and what's the
trade-offs someone for technical
solutions be proposed to improve the
scalability of Bitcoin so that it can
handle more and more users because if
Bitcoin was to become mainstream then it
needs a lot more scalability that it has
right now and the problem is that when
Bitcoin was first created the founder of
Bitcoin who originally published
occurred about a year after he published
a code he inserted a block size limit
well what's called a block size limit in
the code which means that each block has
a maximum block size of one megabyte so
to give a quick recap of how the Bitcoin
network works the Bitcoin network is a
decentralized system where anyone can
run their own node and these nodes will
have a copy of what's called the
blockchain and the blockchain is
essentially a series of blocks that
contain all the transactions in the
system this creator of Bitcoin realized
that there's a potential problem here of
what's called an L a denial of service
attack someone could potentially spam
the network with transactions and make
blocks that are very big and so he
created a limit that each block should
be no bigger than one megabyte and this
limit is hard-coded in all of the
software that you use to run a Bitcoin
client or node on your own computer so
that means your software will
automatically reject any block that is
bigger than one megabyte and now we've
reached a point where blocks are
becoming full they've reached a maximum
capacity of one megabyte and so known no
new transactions can be put in in the
blocks so that gives us a capacity of
around three to seven transactions per
second which isn't very much because
this is now more in the map demand for
more transactions per second in the
network as a network has grown is it a
simple case of if we were able to make
these blocks bigger you could fit more
transactions in
sure yes you can do that if you put the
make the Box bigger
it's a naive and very simple way of
increasing scalability but the main
argument against it from its critics has
been that if you increase the block size
then the block chain itself would get
bigger and that means every single
person who runs a Bitcoin node on their
computers what's called a full mode has
to have all the data of the above the
whole blockchain in order to verify the
whole blockchain correctly if we
increase the block size you would need
more and more storage to store a copy of
the blockchain and this is a problem
because the whole point of Bitcoin is
that as a decentralized system anyone
should be able to run their own node
when this limit was first added in 2009
2010 the Bitcoin wasn't as popular so it
was much easier to modify the code and
insert new changes and uncontroversial
or you know protocol protocol rules like
that
now it's a much bigger space so now hto
change needs a lot more consensus if
you'd like because if you were to if you
wanted to increase the block size this
would create what's called a hard fork
you would essentially create a
blockchain that's incompatible with all
the existing nodes that run on the
Bitcoin network because the existing
nodes they will reject any block that is
bigger than one megabyte and everyone
has to upgrade all the software so this
isn't this is a kind of change that
requires every single person to agree to
it or the majority of the ecosystem to
agree to it
people who want who are thinking about
how to scale Bitcoin kind of really fit
into two camps camps the the people who
are advocates of what's called unchained
scaling and people who are advocates of
what's called off chain scaling the idea
of Unchained scaling is that we want to
increase the scale the capacity of the
Bitcoin network by increasing the number
of transactions that we actually put in
the blockchain itself and you and you
would do that by increasing the block
size and yes that would make it more
expensive to run a Bitcoin full node but
argument is that the majority of Bitcoin
uses their own Bitcoin those anymore
anyway if you have a Bitcoin wallet on
your
on your phone or if you use a web wallet
it's not off it's not a perfect quaint
nerd if your wallet trusts a different
node or some centralized service to some
extent to get information about the
Bitcoin network and get information out
of blockchain so one of the things that
one of the original things that the
original creator of Bitcoin said is that
he expects that as the blockchain grows
in size and ultimately people will no
longer be able to run nodes and nodes
will become super nodes you will have to
have access to data center to run nerds
and that was kind of part of the plan
and but one of the one of the things
that the creator of Bitcoin anticipated
was that Moore's Law would catch up with
the blockchain size so that's regardless
it wasn't me that expensive for someone
to store a copy of blockchain well
unfortunately Moore's law hasn't has
been somewhat dead for the past few
years a hard drive storage has largely
remained at roughly the same cost for
the past few years it's kind of stopped
and that's kind of created a problem so
that's what Unchained scaling is about
the idea of of chain scaling is that
let's move the transactions out of the
blockchain do we really do we really
need to put every small transaction like
if you go to if you go to the coffee
shop and buy coffee does do do we need
to put down the blockchain and we really
want every single person he runs a
Bitcoin nerd to have a copy of that
little transaction so the idea of chain
scaling is let's only put big or
important transactions on the blockchain
and let's put all of those micro
transactions off the blockchain and one
of Percival's for doing that is a system
called the Lightning Network
and the Lightning network is basically
easy something called payment channels
between different individuals to
facilitate off chain payments for
example Alice might send Bob ten dollars
and then Bob sends at least five dollars
in the next day so what they do is
instead of having every single payment
on the blockchain
they just keep a balance sheet between
them and they put all the payments on
their balance sheet and then for example
after a month they say let's see what is
the final balance and let's set all that
balance on the blockchain so you only
need to put that final
payment on blockchain rather than every
single payment in between and you can
extend this at least as a payment
channel with Bob and Bob has a payment
channel with Charlie and less suppose
Alice wants to pay Charlie Alice kind of
route that payment three Bob which would
then send a payment charlie and this is
the idea of black network we use multi
you use a root or a network of payment
channels and you would find the route
between person-to-person that you can
make that payment of the blockchain and
in theory it sounds like a really great
idea but there are some controversies
around it so some people don't think
that it would be very feasible if this
would be beat huge by millions of users
for every single person to find a route
between any other person in this
centralized way because one of the
things with the line network is that in
order to use in order to establish a
payment channel you have to deposit a
certain amount of money which is at
least a minimum amount of money of how
how much she expects to go through that
payment channel and that some people
just don't have the upfront capital so
people expect what's called large
payment help hubs to facilitate that so
you would have a large payment hub that
has a large amount of deposit inside of
it and yo you would route your payments
to that so in some way there's a bit of
centralization involved with that if you
have unchanged scaling we have super
nerds but if you have one chain of chain
scaling we might have large centralized
payment helps so it is still bit of
centralization involved in both Bitcoin
cash when Bitcoin cash folks off from
Bitcoin the value of Bitcoin cash on the
first day was something like 5 trillion
dollars so people were 500 dollars per
coin for free off of there when this
fork happened so it's possible that some
people but the value of Bitcoin has
risen